hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Red Dead Redemption
too I am still Joe and I could hop out
and walk faster let me actually see I
can't hop out I'm stuck here forever we
are stuck here forever
we're stuck here forever I can't even
talk to you talk to me please oh I want
to get off mr. bones wild ride
I gotta think that it might actually be
better just to go and get out of here
sheets sheets I'm gonna do any cheats
cheats are stupid cheats are dumb I'm
not a cheater
help help help I'm just gonna let it go
and hope for the best if something
happens I'll let you know well there
seems to be the most exciting
development is that there's another
carriage on the way let's see what
happens
man I don't know man I don't know but
we're going I guess yeah I see it can we
do something about it
Oh God I can get off mr. bones wild ride
oh thank goodness
all right what do we got here some kind
of problem some money to shoot some
money to do someone need we need to be
active about some let's tell me oh
they're dead okay that's something
okay biscuits okay dead body no it don't
it don't look good
my eyes are open where else are my eyes
gonna be that guy is very I'm literally
right next to you what a moan do you
need me I've been looking at this suit
and tie one bullet cleaned through the
forehead
well my money says this is the handiwork
of a gang called the Lemoine Raiders
Lemoine it's not a real word okay what
have you got okay we should get going
probably over here later to clean this
okay but if we get in that wagon and we
go just as slowly as we work on I'm
going to be unbelievably pissed like you
do not understand how pissed I'm going
to be can I Drive
give it can I Drive can I Drive the
wagon can I get in the driver's seat
please tell me I can drive please oh god
it's not letting me even get in okay oh
boy
okay here we go here we go yes I knew I
wanted to go say hey yeah hey oh hey oh
there we go now we're going on mr. bones
wild
and okay finally time to take this
sumbitch off road I see even I see where
the dots gonna be ha ha switch week miss
we'll miss weeks wish we were
maybe it'll be fine
cuz maybe maybe Dutch will reach theirs
Dutch oh my god Dutch there we go that's
what we needed that needed to happen
I'll direct you okay fine bunch of
ex-army Free Staters without an ounce of
respect for the law
uh-huh why should they damn bravery yes
you trashed baguettes trash my own
original used to say ankle dredges
always rides let me tell you town
preacher and town sheriff rink a sailor
under the table before breakfast
he had one tiny hand like a child on the
end of a grown man's arm but anyway this
tells you what kind of people the
braithwaite's are selling moonshine to
murderers I tell folks don't even speak
to him
don't even look him in the eye sure like
you were saying before that's seven
government officials they've murdered
this year alone yeesh that seems like a
considerable problem you think that the
government would have sent someone after
that that's that's not a localized thing
that's a that's a big deal that's a big
deal here we are
what somebody just screaming pain
unless they start shooting at us and
then we got a big problem hello howdy
good to see you my name is Mark I'm here
to have a good time okay I guess we're
all crouching now
right yeah they definitely can't see us
what did you say I don't remember this
place was crawling with vermin I mean
there's a swamp par excellence as they
say in Paris do they I don't think they
say the Harris back in 708 analyst
well the way I sexually but my friend
here decide you don't have your fine way
with words but he's definitely the man
for the job
righty-ho kind of left kind of guy geez
god damn a horrible Dodgers of tacks
oh you don't need to remind me okay geez
there's no one by the bridge what are
you talking about you're stupid come on
well I guess I'm done crouched now I'm
not gonna go that deep in the muck it's
icky it's icky goopy and I want deal
with it all right now move back scratch
artists meet damn USC Oh sneak damn USA
Oh
deep down USA here we go take it down oh
[ __ ] dude BAM
I'll get this feller trussed up oh yeah
yeah you're good at that all right all
right
all right what about last sue woman is
that gonna help if I last sue em good
and probably not I'll just give them
good with my fists did you do know I'm
gonna see me with this frond
I just pluck a frond and I walk with it
in front of me ain't nobody gonna know
where I gonna be yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
Oh what well okay that was unnecessary
all right way we're gonna hog-tie a
mouse Bo's just as good as anything else
one of that's randomly generated it just
randomly picked something in the nearby
area or my fists all right well I did it
boys I did it these goddamn tax dodgers
have been brush and probably pick them
up okay all right you got it
hell but it oh but it it out of Lula
yeah hey let it hello friend you are a
friend of mine okay just go for a spin
he's gonna pop a few 360s yeah so I want
to make him throw up before I get him on
the on the wagon itself that way we
don't have to deal with a layer all
right come on on this rickety bridge ooh
quick now well this isn't our wagon
where's our wagon okay they're all very
unconscious probably not much brain
damage
what do we do now we better destroy all
this and your boys can handle explosives
sure
a little a little yeah you guys talk
about how great the braithwaite's are
I'm gonna blow this [ __ ] up and I'm
gonna remember from my prior experience
and I need to stand a little bit of ways
from it
what happens if I hold it for too long
probably nothing good huh huh huh huh
huh I'm gonna make a homing Tomic on you
you you and you okay Wow then I'll kill
any of them this thing is weak
[Music]
worried there we go
come on duck man no that's the wrong
place to duck I got three go boom okay
where's more where's more one more
there's another Wang okay I'm getting
better about nailing head shots this is
a little cat whoo hey oh are you
probably yeah okay you got it bill I
don't think the guy's gonna be the
sheriff guns gonna be too happy about
all this murder but they fired first so
I guess got it
all right I think that my beard no it's
not oh [ __ ] yeah hang on okay good
that's it howdy and there's a lot of
loot there's so much loot you're just
gonna leave all this loot dogs is this
good loot man you know moonshiners they
got all sorts of [ __ ] on them
oh man you just gonna leave all this
behind all right let me just get this
guy let me pick up that rifle there I
don't know where my repeater is oh it's
on my horse duh
yeah I will just go I'm looting why
wouldn't you loot your stupid are you
dumb yeah all right I'm on the way one
more one more one more I can't resist
it's like I'm in a candy store it can't
resist I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming
I'm coming didn't leave me buying did
you all right Billy slowpoke come on get
on it hey hello we actually worried
about this did you guys just talk this
whole time yeah well done did you not
see what happened you didn't help at all
and my man must return to our lives
seems like we failed to destroy the last
of the moonshine sure would you like us
to well I normally take it for personal
consumption it's sort of part of the job
but I'd better get back home I do not
just take a jug or two and leave you
boys the rest to show that there's no
hard feelings
[Laughter]
my cousin Webster he used to say some of
us is not as American as others if you
know what I mean only I didn't quite
come on you no-good white-trash
hillbilly piece of scum I know you Billy
lime
[Laughter]
like on a land so stupid a backwater
so backwards even we are like geniuses
come ride with me my goodness we have
really done it this time boys
ello shmoop Dutch that's where you these
two families I mean I really think we
can play this from all sides it's got
Hosea written all over it
this is starting to sound like the young
Dutch again what do you mean
young God said I'm as strong as I've
ever been
hey you know what why don't I race you
back all right fine I'm going I'm good
you listen I'm gonna take so many
shortcuts you don't even understand how
many shortcuts I'm about to take all
right I'm not on a percent sure where
that let me just have it's a little
pause for a second when we see what
desert
[Music]
and you got it okay
says you I'm ahead of you good out there
we're all run you off the road I don't
care if you die I care a little bit if
you die boss bosses actually my dream
come true being able to run alongside
you like this is goddamn amazing I've
never I've never had such a better point
in my entire life I'm so giddy I'm like
a child right now eat my dust loser good
boy he's a good boy
all right now watch this watch this [ __ ]
what's this [ __ ] watch what I'm about to
pull yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't
need to follow no route like you're
taking all I gotta do is what I gotta do
come through this field we can't wait we
can't wait cut through this field
pup-pup yeah we go come on we got to
keep going we gotta push push push boys
boys boys boys boys a little more pushy
pushy I know the jumping's probably
taking it out of ya but don't worry push
you are growing this were you okay on
hurry okay a little faster there okay
horse listen I know that you're tuckered
but uh we gotta go we gotta go we gotta
go we gotta go we gotta go we gotta go
we gotta go do not hit a tree I just
said don't do that
you goddamn [ __ ] you goddamn piece of
[ __ ] horse ball I am mad at you I'm mad
at you huh okay hello wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait mama mama me me me
me me me me Mumbai I win
you were quite so good running away
slowed you down quite so much time is a
bastard ye get to be my age well you'll
know that better than anything we will I
had fun with you today
your I was gonna say you're like a son
to me but you're more than that
Oh dad but dad oh man bad Wow
well this is awkward I'm just brushing
my horse over here I don't know anything
about what's going on over there but uh
you gonna feed my horse a little bit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chopping vegetables for a living I'm
sorry was there insufficient feathers in
your pillow
I ain't lazy mr. Morgan I'll work but
not this what I cook in work
cans there the lady we rescued my
husband and I we shared the work all of
it I was out in the fields I can hunt
carry a knife or use a gun but I tell
you you keep me here I'll skin this fat
old coot and serving for dinner damn
mouth you crazy cop that [ __ ] wife come
with me there run with the man so be it
but we do more than just hunting we run
it and then things hunting us well they
got guns of their own I ain't afraid of
God good
you need anything mr. Pearson maybe me
and mrs. ad are gonna take a little ride
yeah sure there's my list and can you
post this letter for me
while you're there sure come on Princess
are you coming with me damn woman so
polite man I'm a real charmer oh god a
wagon again hopping vegetables to shop
in shut your goddamn mouth
yeah well then listen lady I don't want
to be rude here so I'm not gonna there's
an option to be rude and then not be
rude Oh Robin killings okay but letter
readings where we draw the line
sometime so I pray to the Lord above
your house has not deteriorated further
feel bad now don't you listen since we
last call responded I have traveled
widely making no small name for myself
before you ask I am still yet to take a
wife but I can assure you it's not for a
lack of suitors there was this return to
Tacitus Gogol oh there that's Oh mail we
sent the same alien whenever we set up
somewhere new
Stroud she heads into town doesn't the
start expected mail from us TAS is
killed or whatever they changed it to
now this is odd there's like the first
time that this lady that we rescued and
I've interacted I think this entire time
the most I was like I saw her and choses
like having a tough time of crying on
the side but I think I think this is the
same same person it's hard to tell
sometimes it really is but yeah I would
have thought that there would have been
a lot more interaction from the get-go
but then again the story is not nearly
complete not anywhere close to complete
this is where we're going in is this
place all right
let's giddyup come on places to be
people to see things to do come on
no all right and three two one done what
are we getting while we're really really
this isn't close enough really
oh I'm sorry oh I'm sorry oh I'm real
sorry oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah I know what a starting nothing
again I didn't even start anything to
begin with what are you talking about
just because I ran over some person in a
field doesn't mean anything
golly gee you guys scuse me fancy pants
excuse me excuse me sorry
perdón my okay
hello hey that one please and also I'd
like to pay my bounty my extremely
murderous bounty
this'n and listen there goes all that
all the murders I did in that one town
all forgiven just like what gives me new
life what are you talking about what
give me a new life you talking about
some kind of snake oiler you trying to
sell me cuz I'm buying I would
definitely buy anything laughs real bad
wow you changed your clothes when did
you do that like this lady all right
lady and some new clothes si don't
I can wear what I damn well not like I
told you my husband and I shared all of
the work I wasn't some little wife with
a flower in her hair baking cherry pies
all day yeah I don't doubt that you sure
look the part now won't be long before
you smoke the cigars and playing the
harmonica I'll have you know I used to
learn playing the harmonica before well
my house and everything I own got burned
to the ground I know I'm real sorry
about what you you know maybe I'll keep
my for another one I don't want no pity
just treat me equal and no nobody's
taking nothing for me ever again dig
just don't kill the camp cook
hey there hi what uh what you folks up
to yes and home you're in the morn
Raider country keep it cool you need to
pay a toll to pass through here ah I
don't think so you don't think so
how about you pull over right now that's
what I said Wow
did you
bang
okay goodbye
whoa what it what why
[Music]
yeah little close
[Music]
haha okay man you are bloodthirsty lady
I'm scared and and far too into this
than I ever thought I'd want to be yeah
wait how do I get can I get my drive and
they was clearly planning to bushwhack
us
sniffing around are you gonna tell judge
baby if he is
[Music]
I can't see [ __ ] whoa it's foggy
yeah I've run into them for some local
gang don't seem to grown out of planes
so then anyway oh you go up setting
piercing about that letter
you might dream of it yeah it seems like
man I haven't even read the journal it
is and I have the option to I freakin
wrote it everybody we got dedos and also
we killed like 10 people but they yeah
that's cause for celebration right can I
get are we not going it pulled off
automatically and that is bliss not me
okay whatever here we are hey everybody
hey how's it going here sadly no well
I'd like to say I missed your refined
conversations but I'd be lying I enjoyed
myself out there yes okay that shopping
yes that's shopping Thank You mr. Morgan
don't mention I would ride with you
again mrs. Adler's you will ride with me
maybe if you prove you can handle
yourself well they say I lack finesse
but I ain't afraid of Gunsmoke we got
this if learning you've already done me
a big favor today
oh yeah I think they're flirting nice
oh it's cute
that's real cute hello oh you got going
on over here what kind of operation you
running Xavier Grabbe homestead just
straight up rob a home said okay I want
to live the noble life I want to be a
good guy I wanna uh not do those things
that you want me to do definitely not
okay let me get some food here real
quick I'm actually gonna take a nap
because I think that this character
probably needs it real bad see what you
can find out calmly
I mean sure that janae we both think
there's money to be made
okay I know I'm aware of that
okay hello Tilly plays dominoes what
should we call well he's a wanderer he
probably did something bad came his name
is Kay I love Kane I will die for Kane I
will protect Kane with my life I can't
hey mustardy you
I know I know hello can I hide you
no wait come back come back come back
come back come back
Kane Kane Kane Kane can't Cain Cain Cain
let me Pat you come here good boy come
here good boy I'm will give you a pat
okay come here yeah I'm about you
oh that's a good boy well that's a good
book come here come here can you come on
Cain can be bad yeah Pat's for the pup
Pat's for the pup much forego
shut up don't it wasn't a complete waste
of time
stole this from one of those awful men
you should have it man this family is
dysfunctional man what is wrong with
this camp
excuse me Tilly what is wrong with this
camp I don't know I'm going to bed I
don't understand any of this I'm just
gonna sleep and that's it till morning a
good night I'm gone all right okay so we
examine flour Oh what is this
where'd this come from why why is it
here okay that's a little weird but okay
whatever
also what strange demonic picture is
this who is this
it's Mary might be Mary egg yes
Beatrice Morgan which is Morgan said his
mom must be his mom right okay we gotta
get going we got to get on a mission to
spend too long since we actually the
mission of worth so let's get out of
here we're not gonna Rob anybody we're
not gonna rob a homestead no Sean all
right let's get at it
what should we go we probably Molly
O'Shea Molly needs to speak with me an
honest mistake
who is Molly again Molly who's Molly I
don't remember who molly is but okay all
right then I'll go talk to Molly
hey Molly oh you're Dutchess girl hey
Molly
I call me Molly would you
Artur how he is Dortch I mean how does
he seem to you
I'm about the same as usual I guess hey
you really love them you know what if he
like he always says loyalty is
everything so Arthur excuse me miss I'll
show you what you are I bring a gift a
great gift of information so you got
some tip up so now I can risk my neck
and make you some money while you lounge
around you know Arthur bitterness it it
works on the inside as well as on your
sour face if you say so
you could go find some other fool to run
your errands bill come on over here will
you be my other fool you too Charles
what are you talking Arthur's above a
little stick-up I heard about I'm not
you just said I'll do it as long as you
ride with us I got a serious medical
condition yes you are a compulsive liar
no need to be like that Charles have I
ever lied to you I hardly know you
exactly you do this it's easy and I'll
only take a small commission for my
information but it's now or never
then it's never oh god help me what is
it it's a supply wagon carrying payroll
but very briefly unguarded apparently as
it passes through a crossroads near here
where there's an old ruined church
before it connects with the rest of the
wagon train very easy pick as long as we
get paid or you get shot yeah whatever
but I was just talking to miss O'Shea
and then you come up in here all in my
business I think mrs. O'Shea might have
been worrying about a Dutch
going and thanks for garden and you
don't want in on this Williamson that's
fine by me
it was so a favor hit home just do to
rest you to just have a little faith for
once William Baba scope and jobs like
this since you fellers were knee-high to
a grasshopper scope here exactly told
you here's a wagon with a lockbox passes
through every week they switch out
riders just north of here but the front
wagons by itself for a stretch before
the land run down in the roads okay here
we should cover our faces oh you don't
have to the crossroads up ahead when
soon Williamson crush sakes I should be
do anytime now let's get this quiet and
clean nobody needs to die here okay
whatever you say man clockwork boy I got
a bad feeling about this
just generally speaking I got a real bad
feeling about this
[Music]
don't try anything stupid you know boys
hunter I don't I don't want to get shot
but this is a mistake
I work for Cornwall kerosene and oh
[Laughter]
he'll miss it oh boy I knew it was gonna
be bad it always comes to this here
we're going thanks for shouting my name
out loud that's really helpful that's
our three two look behind you oh nice
nice
well why god dammit what's that oh god
it never sticks to the road anymore
never know oh [ __ ] hello hi I am in the
middle of them they are in the middle of
me I am William Shamu boy oh boy
yeah
okay I'm back guys yeah I'm back okay I
seem to be dodging bullets pretty but
surprisingly
ie I guess I don't need to do anything
here I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming
oh hello excuse me seems like they're
not actually hitting me at all so I
think I'm okay I don't think I'm taking
one hit and I was like in the middle of
them so uh good for me okay um okay I
guess I'll just stop there for a second
I wanted to take in the view okay yeah
they definitely will look at this yeah
sure get some rest
just tuck in take a nap all right
I really wish I could try
I really wish I could just like so hop
down shut up shut up let's just keep
this
[Music]
why do I feel suddenly I'm like I'm the
middle I'm in West world oh why don't
you just tell me partner what you heard
heard some noises out by the bar and a
while ago
Oh Amy better not be all right group
forth hello
go check out the
little doodoo doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo how do I get out of here
never damage is gonna look at them as
they approach to dooba dooba dabble
d-dad enough sure your head inside I'll
go around the back
oh um who Nelly oh uh hello friend I
don't know what I'm doing it the old guy
up there it's full of crap yeah I don't
think they're here don't see any horses
come on let's head back place is empty
oh wow way to go okay we were just and
there's the fire okay all right well
then yeah okay all right we go you get a
face full of that and you get a face
full of that's right in the neck or the
nose I think and you get a face
there we go on this side it's like a
good old barn defender yesh
yeesh can I crouch wham bam oh jeez
BAM
yeah
who's filing in this way oh wait hang on
let me actually let me get my sniper out
for this guy there he goes that's how
you do it okay who else where is he all
areas oh haha you thought you could hide
but you could not oh geez okay this is a
problem all right here we go bang oh
okay and nope
man all right hey let me get this guy
playing dad jeez bang retire I don't
think you retire from this gang so we
got a race against the fire now oh geez
I see that guy alright not where are you
there you are boink there's another one
to your right there I see you yeah yeah
boy here comes two of these guys blank
run the cheap what did I get you try
your hat off
okay
[Music]
why am I just standing up
can I please Crouch Jesus Christ
what the hell is going on I'm on fire Oh
Rick I was supposed to run all right I
didn't realize that I am very on fire
and very dead I was wondering I was
aware I was like why can't I stick to
this anymore why can't I get cover why
can't I shoot oh yeah coz I'm I'm
cooking oh that was supposed to happen
brah Wow bill so strong very impressive
there's a word you got it bub I believe
in you okay and I gotta get my gun out
okay you got it bubs who's there who's
there who's there
yeah usually works for everybody that's
ever ran into the woods before I think
they usually get away definitely with me
okay I don't have my bow but I got a
knife you take the left and I'll take
the right okay you're right a month our
rights are the same you t it oh I see
him I guess I didn't need to come around
to him at all fortunate you done yet
hey can you can you uh you need help
there you are there we go
goddamn it takes so long there we go and
point and point point go for it
what the [ __ ] no I had oh god I had that
god damn you get you bang bang bang bang
bang bang bang there we go that's what
I'm talking about I didn't know you
could cancel out of Deadeye after you've
already had your targets picked but
apparently you can yer nope
thank you for trying oh you're still up
nope nope thank you for trying
don't worry I'm gonna loot this guy
while you try to cut scene man's foolish
we keep messing with Cornwall we're
gonna have to have to do something about
that man miss O'Shea needed my help and
you guys ignore them I need some corned
beef everything all right no I think I
diffused it they stopped turning into
witnesses I think they just moved on so
I think I'm good that worked before
where am I
I am way not that far out not that far
out what is this
who's this Lenny Lenny Lenny I drop
everything for Lenny look Lenny needs a
Lenny gets Lenny need oh [ __ ] wait no oh
no oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god
[Music]
why okay and I think we're good so we
got to get back I'm gonna talk to Lenny
we're gonna have a good time Lenny and I
yeah yeah we're gonna have good I'm
gonna be real sad if anything ever
happens to Lenny let's see if we can
make any sort of like huntin going on
what's that music all about are you
playing music on me also wherever the
hell am I going any animals about
there's an animal come on yeah yeah
sorry bub I need some skins I never seem
to have enough money to star what - not
bad I've not met at many three-star but
then again I gotta go for like the
legendary legendary creatures if I
really want to go for that but I'm not
gonna do that anyway oh yeah and I've
already got some pig ones on there good
pal good pal not a bad pelt
if we can get another app oh come on
boo-boo and some awfully suspicious
music you got going on there not sure
why you would be doing that or feel the
need to do that there's pigs over here
yeah that's - that should be good enough
what do we got here oh no it's not dead
yet each I do appreciate that they made
this more realistic with my god it makes
it but it makes it so much more
impactful every single time it happens
coming up up by pop I mean horse so it's
up there your ass is gonna be full of
belts oh yeah your ass is gonna be so
warm
I'm sorry bub
okay now that I got these I'm gonna go
over see what Lenny wants
I'll probably just donate these the camp
I wonder if there's still fun to improve
the camp I don't know what benefit will
do me long term but maybe you can get a
trapper up in there all right let's go
pump gram oh we gotta go see Lenny oh
and we're back all right hello can I get
um can I can't I'm not gonna get manure
all over the place what are you talking
about the camp funds are low oh well
maybe you were right about something
about the manure all over the place why
can't I cannot get my pelts is it
because you needed to take a [ __ ] and
before you were gonna go over where the
horse excuse me shmoop Oh get back here
you lovely horse all right okay I guess
I can take the pelts off there I guess
you just sell them directly maybe no
know about that one hello hi how are you
doing okay where is the till box
I gotta go donate these
[Music]
hello up here - part of this
conversation okay goodbye
funny of these things just happen in the
camp it does make it feel a lot more
alive than simple behavior loops you
know I'm sure they repeat themselves
eventually but still nice oh wait no no
no no no no I want to contribute I want
to contribute I want to contribute I
want to give goddamnit
[ __ ] animation loops take for [ __ ]
ever okay here we go I want to give
Kalman contribute I'm gonna give items
do this oh yeah god I should give all
these why wouldn't I there we go
yep yep I'm so generous okay oh I'm such
a good guy - look at me look at me
getting nice points how good am I
very the answer is extremely I'm the one
goddamn white knight over here alright
now I can look at this and I can see if
there's an upgrade to get tools oh yes
that's what we need we need the
leatherworking tool so I can get a
better bag so I can carry more [ __ ] and
then ah that's what I need okay I'm
gonna give a bunch of [ __ ] into the
funds 250 was it I think was 250 up up
up up up up up up up up up up up up
morning
more and more and more more more more
MORE ah too much
you've got dim goose come on come on
come on
250 there we go
I'm so good my god am seeing here look
at me how much good did that do me Oh a
lot okay so now we can look at this and
we can buy leatherworking tools and then
I can finally get a bigger sack good see
look I'm the only one here doing it okay
maybe I didn't do anything in the
beginning until forever actually Sadie's
been giving a lot of [ __ ] huh Sadie's
been out hunting give me that [ __ ] yes
can now craft up good for your satchel
yes yes Pierson yes finally I gave you a
bucket of piss don't think I don't know
how leathers made you take an animal
skin you dunk it in a bucket of piss and
that's how you make leather now how
close am i how many of you guys will
work leather out there am I pretty close
it's pretty accurate I think it's pretty
accurate hey you better not be a boring
mission this better not be an emotional
mission it better be us having fun
having a great time I don't want to do
nothing else besides no I mean I got
some clothes on yes out there just
waiting to be stolen why I got something
could be good yeah I was in roads
talking to some of the colored folk they
said there's a gang of fools holed up in
the swamps Easter here who think they
war ain't never ended the Civil War yeah
apparently is still raisin in these
fools mines thirty years later
that ain't my point these ignorant fools
are weapon dealers and in their dealings
sometimes sit on a decent pile of cash
it have been southern weapons to Cuba
and South America for years anyway the
old boy I was talking to reckon there
might be a bunch of cast just sitting
around in Fela net maybe a nice stash of
weapons it's just a bunch of crazies
going exactly well
worth taking a look at at least isn't
happen all right said it was at some
place called Shady bear deep in the
woods okay okay I mean it could also be
a time where we get drunk have a good
fight with them
get some good memories Lenny hear me
okay whatever you say Lenny whatever you
say I'm surprised it's gonna be a shoot
up it always is
I mean I thought that's a bad thing oh
my god this has gotten morning real
quick alright then your or it's pretty
tiny compared to mine huh yeah don't be
embarrassed about Lenny got a pretty
good horse
Schwing cool here's pretty yes not much
of a conversationalist are you Lenny
alright what do I gotta talk on my own
here I think some of them harangue me
and Sadie when we were coming back with
suppliers Sadler did just fine more than
fine actually she's terrified I got a
notion these fellers is one of the same
yeah we won't find no shortage of angry
peckerwood idiots in the state of the
lawn that's the sort is it really that
different in this state
seems like it is these boys got a manner
of wait what the hell isn't it more
notice all respects mr. Morgan you
wouldn't notice if I call you a [ __ ]
lover they see us riding like this but
most of it is a glance or a word and
after day a visit in the night well
we're just out west is out west in your
own who you are decent folks some places
down here hey judge Jimmy oh yes it
can't be so easy for you Lenny
sorry you're caught up in this well I
guess they're gold still shiny and their
guns still shoot so I'm game for robbing
Eddie and every one of these bastards
for all they got okay sounds good to me
it beats being lynched back in
Blackwater with all of you by my side I
guess it does I guess you don't have to
put it that way you make that seem kind
of fatalistic okay I'm just gonna prance
for a little bit here and catch up to
you I'm gonna hit every tree and branch
on the way to our destination the Santa
manic mode is really getting ruined by
the fact that I'm just slamming my
forehead into everything every obstacle
I can get also do you like all the pelts
I have in my horse I wanted to ask you
about that but you didn't say anything
about it so I didn't assume you noticed
well so I keep hitting me get your star
mic with my controller here it sounds
like I don't know what I'm doing how do
you feel like you're close be cautious
that's price smart like you say these
crazies are sitting on weapons no I'm
all for charging in as fast as I can
getting shot immediately yeah
Oh Civil War holdouts see that church up
ahead they're supposed to use it as an
outpost heard they got men going between
here in the big house all day okay
the big house which one's the big house
which house is big how do you know which
one's the house big yeah whatever you
say I don't know some don't smell right
about this maybe it's all the pigs maybe
it's the dead bodies but whatever no
[Music]
that is crazy to think about that like
after the war it's not like anybody
cleaned up every single battlefield some
of them were just left like this sure
knows okay Oh Maxim horse bondage hello
structure
what am i doing madryn Oh whack whenever
all your on me now right behind found it
interesting not sure why his to feathers
out on the road we don't lose them we
give them this much space okay hang on I
was out looking at my journal there
alright let's go let's go let's go I get
it I get it I get it I get it I get it
where'd they go where they go where they
go where they go where they go where
they go I don't see him
what wait what what oh he saw me oh I
don't need okay I get it now
oh I was looking about journalist cuz I
never looked at my journal before but I
didn't know that I was drawing little
sketches like that I bet that would
surprise people that wall up there
there's where am I we decided right ok
I'll take the other side you get in
cover there okay whatever you say buddy
dude yes the militia by the road we do
well to kill them in the one spot if
we're gonna make a pass of this I know
when I see them oh we got something we
can hit them head-on fight I'm honest
well you could go round there acting
friendly friendly with these folks just
charm in one spot then I'll start shoot
no no no no no no no I think that's a
terrible idea
um listen Lennie I'm gonna shoot the
dynamite yeah because I really do think
the other one was dumb boom
[Music]
[Applause]
come on now
oh sorry about that one that was brutal
all right you go have fun with it let me
see if I can shoot this thing whatever
this is missed it by that much missed it
again
three time's the charm there we go are
you trying to shoot me here yeah no you
ducked see you're not supposed to duck
there we go how did I miss that one Oh
goddamn I'm touching right at the end
there I don't know why oh I swear I'm
not this bad guys
okay whatever wingding Tim good thing
they can't shoot me
all right whatever now I'm just pissed
off I saw you come on hop out there oh I
don't think so sir I don't think so I
see it died okay well looking at me then
I see that dynamite okay nevermind what
the hell what the hell what the hell
ya think your think you're definitely
dead
good God how did he get so close to me
yeah I'm making a move - hey buddy I
tried to shoot you from before so I'm
just gonna do it now that point
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
blowing okay there we go I think that
was all of them good god we killed so
many good lord
okay what about grabbing okay water
would grab water would grab what would
grab who would grab him why we'll grab
it okay what about this one is a weapon
crate nope okay what are we looking for
again no we're looking for which one
there's one nope
I'm trying to search the crates Lenny
oh this one oh okay oh that's pretty
good
we sure can go check the rest later
no come on let's go okay alright then
alright to camp we go goodbye everybody
thanks so much for your hospitality uh
I'll show myself out through the corpses
thank you and goodbye
everybody here have a nice day gyah
I mean they're pretty fast these guys
pretty fast probably not good carrying a
bunch of ammo explosives random okay
listen Leslie with your brothers you
don't look like any kind of folk we deal
with our business was conducted to the
satisfaction of all parties until now
that is
nope no something don't feel right about
this not him and not you neither Yankee
get these lines bastard let's not get
these lines bastards cuz I'm gonna shoot
you i'ma shoot you and I'm okay
nevermind I was gonna save a special
shop for you but that'll do
okay everybody say how are we not
hitting you how are we not no song could
bring it in quite a lot late and I
wanted to it's good to have something to
show like this Jones a loudmouth bring
more about what show yeah don't worry
mean Dutch everyone count you know you
do for this guy
we noticed keep it up
you're gonna start seeing things change
okay okay oh that's so sweet me and
Lenny my God we're so close oh that's so
sweet
now look at my horsey coming after me
thank you swoon full schwump a bump a
hose I don't pay hollows a loan babe oh
babe don't be owner why sometimes it
does shortcuts back to the back to the
base and sometimes this is like you're
across the map down run [ __ ] just get
going come on you got hurry up I'm gonna
go yeah thank you I
oh really appreciate your help on that
one never would have been able to find
the place without your help Lanny VME
Linear Tape we're tagging protect it's
all good it's funny he knows I love him
probably yeah it's us that is my name
and that is your name they're good at
that you're good at that Lenny right I'm
gonna keep one just from me hey I always
enjoy riding with you kid you know hey
you two any time off goddamn
Lenny is just the best and I got a
brand-new gun out of it it's a bolt
action it's a bolt action but I bet this
bad boy is so good I hand let me see
this thing let me see oh yeah oh yeah oh
that is what I call good ok did someone
call my name call my name
oh I'm Shawn yep how are you miss O'Shea
around here do you need some help
I don't know about that I think the only
the only quest is gonna be Micah over
here and my god I don't want to go see
Micah but what I can do I think I can go
to the stagecoach and go into strawberry
somehow yeah maybe I couldn't use the
stagecoaches because I had a bounty on
my head that's entirely possible
I mean it would make sense considering
that they probably wouldn't want to give
me anything credible yeah well I'll try
because if I can it would save me a big
big big big big amount of time and I
don't have time to waste come on come on
horsey let's go into town let's go see
something about a stagecoach I know that
other horse that I have is somewhere out
in the middle of nowhere somehow still
loyal enough to me to stay out there no
way it's over there oh well this is
awkward
other horsey I just don't care enough so
goodbye alright let's go get the
stagecoach and then let's go see Micah
it's it's it's amazing how much my one
encounter with Micah my one mission
alone with Micah has made me so
adamantly against working with Micah
like it's like it's visceral for me I
just cannot do it because I hate him so
much like what a [ __ ] stain of a human
oh god damn it why is it locked off damn
it alright I guess I'll go on foot then
[ __ ] fine I guess we're going yeah I
mean that's a it's like a contribution
to the writing of the game
only three on that hill I'm gonna see
that tree I want to see that tree that's
a nice tree it's a nice tree on that
hill over there I wanna go over there
just because I like that tree
yeah but Micah like I I know that this
game is probably gonna throw the gambit
of characters that I do like and not
like I mean don't get me wrong one thing
I like about like stories and stuff like
that is I don't care if I'm supposed to
not like a character like if I if a
character is written to be hated that's
great
that means the character is well written
but if it's like if there's a potential
for a character to be so viciously evil
I want the writers to take every liberty
in making that character the most evil
character that it could possibly be
because that's good writing that's just
good storytelling I feel like that's
needed that has to happen or else there
wasn't any point in doing it in the
first place yeah cuz cuz it's like
without it without it you just end up
with oh you oh there you go without it
you just end up with characters that are
boring and like with with humanizing
characteristics and in a way it is
humanizing to have someone that's just
so viciously horrifying that you hate
him oh three star but then again that
can happen to everybody no I didn't
upgrade my satchel
Oh God Pierce and I meant to go over to
you god damn it I've got so many hides
I've got so many hides all right I'm
gonna save these sides to whatever I
eventually make my way back to Pearson
which I will perfect
dear felt hey wait a minute
hey wait a minute how many pelts you got
there
horse you you hold Mac on me horse yeah
this is the thrill Hill
this oh there's stuff here what the hell
it's like target practice game so much
it's also like I'm catching myself
because I'm getting so engrossed in the
game that I'm going into like my normal
like long-term gameplay mode where I'm
just like sink into a blank expression
don't talk at all and then just go play
the game and I have to remind myself
that's like oh [ __ ]
I'm dude a video I make a videos I'm
like that oh this is this game is so
engrossing like I could definitely see
myself playing this game all day for
weeks at a time
what the hell okay I don't know what
that was
oh look at this alright sorry Bob I
don't know what that that was a horrible
like sci-fi horror movie squealing going
on over there
Oh shouting whoa shoten it's not a very
reassuring thing when I have about to
stab it I go it's okay it's like it's
not okay oh my god that's beautiful
I mean not necess not this but look at
the landscape anytime I say something's
beautiful it's usually the landscape
here we go hey boy boy oh boy I've got
to be getting close now Michael what who
is shooting the target practice or what
plan whatever it don't matter
oh wait am i near EG oh I am but I
really don't want to oh my god I'm so
far from Micah okay I'm just gonna go
I'll be back once I get over there
here mr. Kenya I've been on Oh for days
now help me with these shackles I just
might have a chance
okay just shoot the chains off please
done for otherwise hold still hold still
hold still
oh oh yes yes perfect
ah thanks I I got no money to give you
but I think I might got something even
better some of those fellows talked
about this old crone of North a
strawberry got herself a tidy sum locked
away maybe just stories but they were
sure excited oh yeah why would I be
interested in that huh I'm just a hunch
it's up to you friend all right whatever
you say I'm not much for home robberies
they make it a little too stressful for
me so I don't know if I'm gonna be down
for that but
[ __ ] it in there I might be interested
oh there's something going on over there
but I gotta get over to mica god that's
the thing about this game this is like
because I'm flabbergasted at the amount
of content that's in the main storyline
like 40 hours of gameplay in the main
storyline but just imagine how much
content is in the side storylines just
imagine how much content oh my god it's
so pretty oh it's so pretty just imagine
how much content is gonna be in like
DLCs and stuff like this how many years
did they spend working on this game God
if it's been since the first one that
they've been working on this one it's
been eight years I still marvel at that
idea the idea that it's just such a huge
team of people so much money put into
this game so much work put into this
game so much effort just getting it
right every nuance hey I mean I've
encountered some bugs but you're never
gonna get rid of all bugs in a game you
never make anything actually perfect
especially when things are a little bit
procedural and all over the place but oh
my god I always come back to it I always
come back to it just how beautiful this
isn't how scary these woods are I was
thinking about it again you know how
there's some piers some experiences that
I'll never be able to do I mean I
recommend that everybody try to have as
many experiences as you can but there's
some things that I'm like I guess I may
never in my life go to space no matter
how much I love it just because you love
something doesn't mean it's gonna happen
I didn't spend my life working towards
that goal so you know that's not gonna
happen
and I mean it's a pretty common thing to
be shared with a lot of people in in
human society but at the same time it's
like man I wonder I wonder what else I
could do that could make myself go even
farther I wonder where I could go with
my life I wonder what I could do that
could really push me even further than
I've come already and I've come pretty
far I know that I recognize that very
much so but I still think about that on
a daily basis I really do I think about
what I can do more about well good I
could do like how I could do more
because I always want to push myself
until I can't push myself anymore
and not that this game and this
character reminds me of that but the the
people who made this game remind me of
that they make me think about that I
think it's a fascinating part of the
human experience to try to keep pushing
yourself as far as you can until you
can't push anymore so oh whoops I
thought I needed to be somewhere else
all right let me hop off actually ah
well I'll just have to wait till they
actually make Westworld then I can just
enjoy this experience
all that I want hello hi if you think
about this is just a different version
of Westworld it's the only way we can
make it right see you know I got a plan
to make it up to you I'll plan like the
blackwater ferry job or like you going
off scouting and ending up in jail
Dutch said you was a a big shadow cast
by a tiny tree I don't even know what
that means I thought you was a tough boy
not one of those gentlemen trying to
protect his riding clothes just know
whenever things get real you tune yellow
lose your head yellow I guess you won't
be riding with me to rob the banking
coach comes about this time in the
strawberry I heard one of the old
Driscoll boys yappin about it while I
was inside you Oh God Driscoll's robbery
that's what I said after you dude I
totally forgot about the old Driscoll's
I didn't even realize it Oh Driscoll's
we're still thing I'm worried about
Caldwell my god I got so many worries
enemies out here like some crazy hermit
can I like I told you I ain't going back
to Dutch without a peace offering so
what's the deal with this coach what do
you mean
comes through about this time every day
like I said the end I mean how many men
riders nothing serious it'll be fine I
heard the bank's been hired every
trigger man they can get inflate the
meter the better you worry too much
forgive me if I ain't wholly faithful in
something in oak Tristan told you when
you was half drunk in a jail cell
he can't be happen about saying how
they've been hitting it on the regular
that's a good lead in my book damn old
Driscoll's are everywhere if they've
been hitting it on the Reg Valley
birth they took over some big ranch
North Academy right then wouldn't keep
sending anyway oh you know how it is few
loose ends drink here drink their water
loose it's nothing that needs to concern
you I always pay my share it concerns me
when you put us in danger and we don't
realize till it's too late like that
move you pulled a strawberry making me
kill half the town just for your
precious
precious they are you need to roll a
little looser Morgan I seen you come
full on done more than once now and you
only been running with us a few months
are we gonna rob this coach for bigger
about it what's done is done
Robin and let's do it
wait if mike has only been here a few
months and he goes Full Tilt and you
just you get rid of him he's obviously a
bad influence on all this we ain't
brothers I ain't gonna be here about
this but also I just remembered yeah
he's not back at camp so we haven't seen
him interacting with everybody I wonder
if that's gonna change or if I'm we're
gonna have an unfortunate accident with
Mike on the receiving end of some
untimely high-velocity projectiles maybe
maybe not we'll see what happens
all right Mike at where are we going
where are we never been up here I've
never been up on a mountain now I didn't
even know these mountains were things
that you could actually climb
love it though all right this is the
spot okay hold up on this Ridge yeah
yeah yeah I'm sure this is gonna go
great and a lot of people aren't gonna
end up dead yep
they should be here in a little bit hold
tight
which way will they be coming in should
be from over there we need to hit them
fast before they get into town don't
lose your head this time course tough
guy they should be here any minute
yep I knew it god damn it Micah you sack
of [ __ ] oh come on it's freaking day now
what the hell any minute day okay all
right I got you oh you guys are getting
serious about this
hey okay this is not going as well as I
wanted it to can I get out of the trees
blaze the new gun I need to get used to
it
all right I'm good with this nice gun
[Applause]
this is funnier this is murder
all right well then I guess we're done
here
so you're gonna drive is covered why you
gotta be antagonizing you know just cuz
I'm antagonized yeah
half a fight but neither of us got hit
what happens when I know Driscoll comes
along and tries to rob us oh there we go
a favorite weapon ranking 13 and 59 ooh
familiarity I didn't even know familiar
8 it was a thing in guns is that why my
guns got better say why I got better
with him that would make a lot of sense
Dodd would make a lot of sense where
some of these guns that I haven't used
in a while
ah familiarity very low but this new
bolt-action I'm already getting some
familiarity with it that's so
interesting how about Mike my pistol
very familiar okay anyway I think this
is gonna be my new favorite gun there
what did I tell you well I can lick 14
looks in it
and there might be a second crew of
riders feel alright not to mention we
ride back in with a big tank new wagon
to poop judge can't say we pulling our
weight no more Kenny alright sure I
trust this new rack to your swamp bit
with
we got off on the
but I got no beef with you I'm wrecking
we're a lot alike you would be I'm a
feller that gets things done
hey miss you things done you'd be
wearing California collar now if I had
broken you had a chair and I have
expressed my gratitude
have I not it's done anything
Oh what oh I called it oh I called it oh
[ __ ] oh boy I called that I called that
good
okay where's my gun well you wouldn't
hold up against this bulletproof coach I
am slightly less nevermind I'm good yeah
I like this gun even though that was a
Miss I think he fought double camp oh oh
oh come on let me get this one boy yeah
and knock that guy's mask off not that I
was exactly uh quick about it
[Music]
wagon
oh I don't look good Oh got him in the
knee they'll never survive that all
right damn why are you just standing in
the middle you fool you frigging idiot I
mean I learned my lesson about that long
time ago and I'm Here I am doing it
again I guess oh boy this this gun is
powerful not that one alright well done
well done um but we've got a problem the
good points why does you guys clearly
ain't going nowhere now that's all right
[Music]
well this little mess all right well I'm
not sure what you mean oh [ __ ] how am I
not hitting this thing I am come on
let's see if all this new world I see is
you me a river full of Dano Driscoll's
and a lockbox I bet there's nothing in
it
I'd say we're golden here Morgan look
all right fine what's the cut here
there's good just make sure the gang
gets its page yeah yeah like I said big
shadow tiny tree
and lack ass that still don't mean
nothing yeah that making sense see touch
make sure like small dogs big barn oh
it's been fun oh so now he's back at the
camp now
whoa oh yeah oh yeah oh wait wait wait
wait whoa whoa you know I'm gonna get
out of here you know I'm just gonna get
out of here I'm gonna get out of here
you know I don't need to be here I don't
need nothing about this I'm gonna go
over here and forget any of this ever
happened
nothing here for me nothing nobody not
me I didn't do it so you don't even need
to worry about any of that where can I
go next I want to get back into town but
it's super far away so I gotta see if
there's something else here that I can
do while I'm over here that looks like a
big negative there so big old no one
that one only I was back here while we
were back here cuz then it wouldn't be
so goddamn far yeah well it don't matter
I guess I got to get back there no
matter what there's nothing else to
going on Abigail wants something
advertising the new American art okay I
don't know what that means but alright
alright anyway that'll do it for this
episode here thank you everybody so much
for watching I will be back in town by
the time you see the next one so thank
you so much and as always I will see you
in the next video